- Hey, come on it.
(pop music)
Yes, Push & Believe, you got it.
You know, I don't
need these notes.
- Go on, go on,
look at your notes.
- My writers are good, okay?
Born and raised in LA.
- Born and raised in LA, got it.
- I was raised in
LA, so were you.
Very close to your mother,
and she remembers that,
as a child,
you always wanted
to be a comedian.
- She asked me what
I wanted to be,
and I said I wanted
to be a comic.
When you're young,
you're insecure,
and you don't know what's
going on in the world.
I mean, I use humor to
deal with everything,
so it became natural later
to become a stand up comic.
- You quit your job.
You had a day job.
- Yeah, well I feel like,
if you really want to be
an actor, comedian, or
anything in the arts,
if you have a job or
whatever else you're doing.
If you have to ask someone
permission to go do
stand-up or an acting gig,
that means that's
your real priority.
So I say that, like,
if you have the opportunity
to chase after whatever it is,
go after that, you know,
because, when you're a comic,
you learn how to be frugal.
You know, we can live
off of $10,000 a year,
just learned how to... (laughs)
- It's hard to do.
I need my coffee.
I've got...
Wait, what was your job?
You were a CEO at a...
- I know, right.
Fortune 500 company.
- You're on the road
every weekend now.
Now you're not playing Montana.
You're playing the big clubs,
you're selling them out.
They know you from
Workaholics, you're Montez.
Question.
What does tight butthole mean.
(laughs)
That's one of your taglines,
I've seen it on Twitter.
Montez.
- You saying that is
so frickin' hilarious.
Alright, on the show,
if something's good,
- Uh-huh.
the boys call it tight butthole.
- Tight butthole.
- They like your shirt, that
shirt's very tight butthole.
If something's bad, they
call it loose butthole.
- Loose butthole.
(laughs)
But, you're tight butthole.
- So this interview right now,
you're getting a special
with very tight butthole.
- Yeah, and I'm
into anal energies.
I heard recently, and it was
shocking when I heard this,
that you actually got into a
fight, you punched a heckler.
- Like me in a fight, right?
- Yeah.
You wear glasses,
you're not violent.
- Sweetest guy in
America right here, okay.
They already tried to
tell the guy to shut up,
but he wouldn't shut up.
So, then he starts in with me.
And then I lit
into him, you know.
- Lit into him, you got in.
- I was on fire and I was
antagonizing him on purpose.
I actually got the
reaction that I
probably subconsciously wanted.
Then the guy rushed the stage.
- How'd he get up there
with his wheelchair?
- You motherfucker, you're
not supposed to tell people.
- Alright, both you and
I, we mentioned earlier,
we grew up in LA.
- Grew up in LA.
Similar energies, positivity.
- Tryin' to be.
I say, we're both on Instagram.
I wanna feel like I
can read your body,
read your...
- What are you sayin', like
you're gonna be able to see
you know what's going
on on my Instagram
without even looking at it,
is that what you're
trying to say?
- Yeah. Let's go for it.
This will test how close we are
in terms of two Angelinos.
Okay, I have my photo chosen.
- Alright, well let
me pick a photo.
Oh, I know exactly
what photo to pick.
- Alright, look at my photo,
I'm gonna guess yours first.
You're lookin' at, there's
a guy with glasses.
A mustache.
Cool hair.
- Really?
- So, me?
You're saying it's me.
On my Instagram, you're
saying that it's me.
Okay, very good.
Let me, let me...
- Was I right?
Yeah, it's actually...
- It is you!
I was right!
Okay, now try and read mine.
- Yours it probably
like, you know,
there's a beard.
Glasses.
Probably hair.
Maybe it's like an aunt
that you look like.
- [Brody] You know what?
- [Eric] Let's see.
- I don't know how you did that
but, check that out.
- Yes!
That is my Aunt.
You got it. You read the energy.
Ladies and gentleman,
- 818 til I die.
my aunt.
There she is, my
father's brother.
We have Eric Griffin.
Brody and Griffin LA united.
Yeah!
Push & Believe.
(laughs)
- Push and believe?
That's what you say in the
delivery room to your wife.
- [Both] Push and believe.
- Here she is, let me
cut the umbilical chord.
- Until a black baby comes out.
- You got it. Push
and confusion.
I'm the Lance Armstrong
of Comedy Central videos,
and I'm sitting on my
testicle right now.
Subscribe.
Comment.
Like me.
DM me.
Tweet me.
Send me an IM.
Follow me home one night.
Peddle with me to Twitter.
To Facebook.
Like the videos.
You wanna go bike
riding with me?
I'll do what it takes
to go viral.
(burping)